[Applaudissements]
une ambiance de soirs de match bernard
laporte invité d'honneur pour le voile
ans en grandes pompes sa coupe du monde
de rugby scolaire
cette première en france l'école
catholique voit grand une semaine de
tournoi 24 collèges de la planète en
compétition dans un cadre atypique on a
le terrain qui sera sur le domaine
communal
mais on souhaite avoir une forme de
campus pour accueillir les 700 élèves
avec des tentes des zones de
restauration le terrain devant une
abbaye millénaire
avec le regard du monde entier c'est
c'est très inspirant et c'est un moment
fort pour des enfants des enfants prêts
à en découdre pour représenter leur
école dans deux ans certains élèves de
6e défendront les couleurs de pontlevoy
mettre tout cet excité on va être fou
pourquoi pas parce qu'on a envie de
gagner on va
c'est un match c'est une grosse
compétition qu'on va jouer dans la tête
on va être concentrée y aura beaucoup
d'ambiance on
essaie de gagner
[Musique]
la compétition arbore le label de la
coupe du monde 2023 une semaine avant le
grand événement ses organisateurs
veulent promouvoir la pratique du rugby
auprès des plus jeunes vous avez sur un
terrain de rugby vous verrez quasiment
jamais un joueur contesté une décision
de l'arbitré et c'est un élément
important d'éducation de savoir qu'on
peut respecter les règles de savoir que
on peut dans le cadre de ce sport se
dépasser pour vie sur un terrain de
rugby à cette notion de performance
collective qui était pourtant toutes ces
valeurs là c'est toutes ces valeurs
qu'on souhaite inculquer aux jeunes
parmi les principaux financeurs du
tournoi des sponsors les collectivités
locales mais également d'anciens élèves
de l'établissement